[Musique]
ça nous sommes sûrs dans la série l'été
de se re je vais vous parler de sujets
dont je vous ai pas déjà parlé avant des
sujets plutôt nos cours de l'année et
que malheureusement j'ai pas eu le temps
pas eu l'occasion pas eu l'opportunité
de mettre en ligne et aujourd'hui je
vous parlais de robotique pendant parle
un petit peu son achat n'est pas
suffisamment et l'oeuvre ne veut pas
être robotique plutôt destiné à un usage
professionnel mais qui néanmoins
intéresse beaucoup de monde parce que on
est très nombreux aller au travail
je sais que pas mal d'entre vous sont
pas encore concernés parce qu'ils sont
soit lycéens soient collégiens soient
étudiants ou alors ne bosse pas pour
l'instant
toujours est il que ça finira bien par
nous arriver un jour ou l'autre et pour
certains d'entre vous vous allez vous
retrouver dans les espèces de grands
bâtiments tous les qualité de l'air est
pas terrible où la luminosité est pas
terrible
et justement il ya un robot qui pourrait
vous aider vous aider à respirer
beaucoup mieux à optimiser et votre
environnement travail s'appelle d'iron x
c'est un robot français que j'ai pu
rencontrer cette année des nous envier
aux crs à las vegas
on va faire un retour dans le temps
retour d'un coup dur pour aller au mois
de janvier au cio est si on y va
maintenant
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au c
es avec ramesh qui est la société par
touring robotics qui lie à un robot
super intéressant justement vient nous
présenter alors
[Musique]
non
jaras a pas que ton petit robot qu'est
ce qu'il a comme solution
alors ce redoux s'appelle et dia one est
ici sur le sillet ce 2018 pour présenter
la dernière version de yahoo à nice
le robot du bien-être
au bout du vieillir presse qu'il importe
comme jamais
il fait c'est que c'est un mot qui va
mesurer toutes les formes de pollution
que je peux avoir dans les
environnements intérieurs soit la
démission par la qualité vers la
pollution par la luminosité la pollution
par le bruit d'une mauvaise température
une mauvaise humidité doivent tous les
paramètres physiques du bien-être dans
les environnements intérieurs donc ici
en termes d'environnement sonore déjà
vous assurer qu'en lisant rouge vichy
rouge
c'est un petit peu compliqué mais il
fait pas que mesurée voilà ce qui est
bien c'est que grâce à sa navigation il
sera là dans les organes
on mesure mieux syrie par l'air d'accord
quand il est équipé d'une technologie
c'est la même qui a dans les salles
d'opération nouveau décor donc à qui
purifie 99 95% tout ce qui passe dans
son réacteur
il crée une bulle d'air pur et donc à
l'intérieur des bâtiments grâce à diallo
à mixer les gens peuvent respirer un air
frais là aussi pas de donner des
indications son niveau sonore
il ya trop de bruit on va faire
attention les gars à un petit château il
ya introduit mais a pas assez de lumière
donc c'est vraiment une source
d'information et c'est aussi un robot
qui prend des actions pour le bien-être
des patries stipule tu me parle par
exemple de lumière est-ce qu'il peut
agir directement sur la lumière est ce
qu'il est connecté
lumière intérieure puisque imaginer
qu'ils soient connectés par exemple avec
l'amazone alix avec google assistants
dont j'aurais imaginé tout ça bien sûr
sans aucun problème aujourd'hui ce qui
fait les gersois c'est qu'il va dire
tiens par un plat ya une base de données
sur
vous n'hésitez à tel endroit on tient là
c'est ça manque de lumière où il ya trop
lumière d'une telle base d'informations
pour que le responsable ici depuis si
elle tient là il ya peut-être des néo
inchangé où il ya peut-être à revoir un
peu la configuration de la pièce pour
elle si on est vraiment sûr côté
informatif et par contre est à vous
d'être vraiment lui actif c'est sur la
circulation de l'air c'est sur la
qualité des roues l'aï pas vraiment
traité d'accord un camp qui l'a des
actions d'information et les actions de
traitement génial alors la cible de ce
rebond on s'adressait qui coûte
aujourd'hui même s'ils coûtent aux
professionnels de l'entreprise
bref est donc on est sur l'abitibi
voulait dire avec l'âge de 3 ans donc
c'est à dire les grandes entreprises et
les grands comptes dans les tours mais
aussi dans les centres commerciaux dans
les musées dans les grandes écoles
voilà il ya vraiment un potentiel très
intéressant surtout des bâtiments
intérieur ok ok et pour le particulier
est ce que c'est un produit qu'on peut
se procurer
quand tu penses que c'est quelque chose
qui va davantage se démocratiser dans
les années à venir
après tout à fait donc mon réfléchit
déjà à une version turbo qui va pouvoir
être un peu plus compacte haut
ouart est justement dans les foyers dans
les maisons mises en vente non de techno
qui à l'intérieur on aura vu déjà scellé
on a cherché à combien robots comme ça
avec le temps c'est un budget est pas si
élevé que ça c'est à partir de 1000
euros par mois les prix mais pour ça tu
as le robot à sa base de recharge
puisqu'il va se recharger tout seul vers
la maintenance le changement d huile de
l'accès au big data ce qu'il fait des
mythes data mobile est quand même génial
donc ratatouille et packages à une sorte
de formule tout compris
en fait ce qui est génial avec ce robot
jiahua nice et que ces deux plateformes
ouvertes
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui fait la
qualité d'un on peut rajouter d'autres
services comme la sécurité la silver
economy s'occuper des personnes âgées
break the sky's the limit comme vous
dites aussi s puisque est génial si tu
vois c'est le seul robot qui a de la
belle communauté européenne et origine
france garantie
il est produit son concert à à cergy en
france on est super fiers de ça donc
n'hésitez pas
achetez se polit français génial alors
tu parles du label je connais pas ce
label qu'elle concerne quel type de
produit c'est la robotique en
particulier c'est alors on a deux labels
donc le label cee communauté européenne
dont elle a passé toutes les normes en
termes de sécurité des données sécurité
des trous magnétique sécurité électrique
sécurité physique extrêmement important
il ya plein de monde sont retirés la
circulation aux états unis resteront pas
passer la sécurité physique bien sûr
delà de la belle angie france garantie
on est super fiers de ça ça veut dire
que le robot il est produit en france et
vérifier tard un groupe formidable qui
est porté par yves jégo qui dévie si
bien que toutes les faits en france
produit entendu ces sujets bien génial
et une parler de big data donc vous avez
en stocker des informations
kirby équipés de réseaux de capteurs
d'accord qui collecte de l'information
et ensuite on se sert de ces
informations pour donner les indications
pour rencontrer des index de confort sur
l'ex sur la qualité de l'air sur le
bien-être global allons vraiment y les
paramètres dont on a vraiment un système
transactionnel qui est extrêmement
intéressant les informations que vous
stockez dans le robot ou stockées en
ligne
alors on a des informations qui sont
dans le robot mais il ya aussi des
informations qu'on envoie directement si
les gens me souhaitent sur une taxe le
cas donc on avait deux modèles merci
beaucoup je vous invite vous les ayez
commentaire rien dire ce que vous en
pensez parce que c'est vrai que la
robotique c'est quelque chose qui se
développe énormément on le voit vraiment
sur le csk une très très grosse présence
en termes de robotique
là on est sur du made in france cocorico
c'est génial laissez moi vos
commentaires vous invite à laisser des
jolies pouce pour moi et pour cette
jolie starter abonnez vous on reste
connectés
s'il n'y a pas encore plus de contenu en
entreprise française innovante et pour
la itech ciao merci saint lunaire si
l'on peut revoir